um
so my name is aaron stein uh i'm
here from uh charlottesville virginia
today and uh if my connection holds out
uh we're gonna try an international
webrtc call here
uh if not i'm going to blame several
different internet providers and
take no responsibility at all just to
warn you
so my my company's agility feat
we are in in the us
and central america uh primarily
in costa rica we build real-time
applications
uh lately we've particularly gotten into
webrtc so
if you want to try and join into this
it's been a little spotty i
actually uh did actually visit a volcano
a couple weeks ago in central america
and i did not make the proper sacrifices
to the demo gods and
since i'm seeing that today so
but you can go to
webinar.agilityfeed.com and you can log
into the same application and give it a
shot if you like
and what what this does is you you can
make some comments in there you should
see the slides changing on your mobile
device
that sort of thing so
we we built this application as a way to
play around with a couple of different
things one is real-time messaging
and the other is uh webrtc which is one
i'll focus on now but i'll just briefly
mention the real-time messaging side of
it
for now real-time messaging is is uh
you can implement in a number of
different ways what we did in this is a
published subscribe model using a
commercial provider called pubnub that
we have no connection to they gave me a
frisbee at a conference once but that
was it um
but we particularly like it for this
sort of thing and what it's nice for is
is it's a publish subscribe data model
so
great for building like chat
applications or
like in this letting letting people pass
votes on a presentation
and consolidating up that up on the
screen that sort of thing
and
then the second part that i want to
actually focus on though
is webrtc uh how many of you are
familiar with webrtc already
okay pretty good number good uh any of
you building
applications with webrtc right now by
chance
one sort of i would say we're sort of
two
webrtc is an emerging standard in in
html5 it's it's very new it's very
leading edge so if i can't blame
internet providers i'll just blame the
standard
that this is all you know pretty early
but but it's really fun to play with
right now
and uh there are production apps
starting to appear with it
uh webrtc stands for uh web realtime
communications
and the uh the simplest example of how
you
how you use it that most people would
know it for is building video chat
directly into the browser with no
plugins necessary no downloads
no flash that's the great promise that
it offers
and so people kind of debate uh could
you use webrtc
to kill skype or facetime or other
applications
i don't know that you really would but
but you can build that type of
functionality
into directly into your applications
and this is a quick little um uh and by
the way
i'm assuming that you can't see me on
that one
cool good we're you're seeing it too
awesome
yeah good good well that makes me feel a
little better then
so this streams this we're streaming
through uh webrtc
out to anyone who logs into the
application uh
my colleagues in costa rica and boston
who are uh logged into this right now
are hopefully hearing me as well
and uh uh so
the way the way that this works from an
architecture perspective it's
peer-to-peer
after some handshaking so what you see
in the diagram that i've shown you here
is you've got two clients
let's say laptops is most widely
available in desktop browsers right now
and by widely available i mean sort of
half available actually
firefox firefox and chrome
support webrtc opera just recently
started supporting it
ie and safari do not yet
and there is a question mark of whether
they will or not
that's really kind of the biggest risk
to implementing something in webrtc
right now is it's unclear
if apple or microsoft are going to
support there's
strategic reasons you might say that
they should never support microsoft owns
skype and link which arguably webrtc is
a
is a disruptive threat to those
applications and on the apple side
you have face facetime which is also
arguably just a threat
to that so some people say that maybe
they won't support it but they're
they're starting to show some signs that
they will support something like
eventually i think they will eventually
but it may not be
this year okay but this is still a great
time to start building these
applications because you can really do
some disruptive things with it and
you really want to be ahead of your
competitors
so the way it works you got these two
laptops
both in chrome and uh
or firefox and you have to go to
a central you know some sort of
agreed-upon application right you have
to have
some sort of meeting place when you're
both in that application
it's going to do some handshaking
between you so there's a third party
server here that i'm
showing at the bottom of the diagram
that does what webrtc calls signaling
which is basically saying i want to call
jarrod
he gets a message from me and agrees to
have a video chat with me so that signal
goes back through the third party server
to me once we have established a
connection with each other
from then on webrtc does
peer-to-peer connections between us and
and that peer-to-peer
connection is uh encrypted by default
which is kind of cool
uh so there's uh uh i'm sure that there
are certain you know agencies in
washington dc that
could probably break into it if they
really wanted to but it's at least an
appealing concept
uh that you can have completely private
encrypted conversations through this and
as i mentioned later that it has
some real business applications too like
in healthcare for example
so once you're once you're talking it is
peer-to-peer
video and audio there's also a data
channel in there too which it doesn't
get as much attention because
people are just starting to kind of
think about the possibilities of using
that data channel
so any uh any questions so far
is there graphics being thrown
through webgl or is it something
different the
uh so that's the other big debate going
on in the webrtc
world right now is the video codec that
they use
there's competing two competing
standards
for that that is slowing down the
adoption
some but once you have the video stream
it's all just displayed through an html5
video tag
and i'll show you the code for that it's
very simple it's all javascript
basically uh any other questions so far
cool okay question yeah um
one of the things that seems to me you
might recall correctly that skype is
doing special is when they're dealing
with
with home computers behind routers so is
there any issue with that here
that the two-way connection business and
and when both parties are behind
yes there is a there is an issue with it
which is why i was just checking my mifi
to see if my connections come back
because oddly enough or perhaps not so
ugly um
just be i got here a little early and
was trying to test some calls with with
my colleagues
uh for this and we couldn't do it over
the shutterstock guest network that you
may be on right now
uh it apparently is blocking the
the streaming video access right so
uh this is a this is a challenge and um
there's basically two different ways
that
generally speaking that you can
establish a webrtc connection right now
that one is to
implement the standard yourself which is
what this diagram here
is roughly showing one example from
html5 rocks
the other is to use an api we're using a
an api from pubmed they have a beta
webrtc wrapper that basically handles
the networking for you
but what the webrtc webrtc standard
talks about is when when things are
behind
firewalls you have to use a variety of
different
protocol stun turn ice servers to try
and
get a connection through the firewall to
the other client peer to peer
so you do have a couple obstacles here
you know first you have to be in
supported browsers
second you have to be able to
communicate peer-to-peer
uh with each other and do one of these
you know fancy networking tricks
i'm not a networking guy which is why i
like apis i don't want to have to
implement
or host stun and turn servers myself
so the so i like the idea of using you
know
a commercial platform that will handle
that stuff for me basically and also
simplifies the code so it is a challenge
it's something to be aware of
and it is uh a possible obstacle to
adoption in the enterprise
for webrtc uh and uh
but but to me anyways i think a lot of
the innovation around this is going to
be in the consumer space
initially so that's not as much of a
concern there
is one of the most prominent providers
right now
of webrtc api and tools
one of the things that i'm pretty sure
talkbox does
and others at least are working on
is if you can't support a webrtc
connection
and what you're doing then they build in
ballpads
so that you can still have people in
other browsers
you know together in the same
conversation so that's going to be one
of the
advantages of using uh you know a
provider who
who handles that for you
but they're definitely a big name you
know in space still
well worth looking at
okay so
to someone's question uh i mean this is
it's
absolute simplest form this is basically
what you're doing
uh when you uh set up the connection in
javascript
you're calling git user media which is
uh
provided by html5 now you
you tell it whether you want the audio
and the video
you pass in those those parameters that
you want and
it returns back to your callback method
a stream
and then you just put that stream into a
video tag and
poof magically you have video in the
browser
in its simplest form that's that's all
you're doing of course there's there's
always more to it
okay uh so there are a lot of different
applications of this
um let
let me try
and call someone
i think that particular one's going to
work uh mariana if you're hearing me you
probably need to make a new comment in
there
it made me quite much better stuff so
let me just turn the wi-fi oh okay
let me uh cancel that there
okay good so mariana can hear me and i'm
going to
going to try and switch over here real
quick so
okay always
look at this one more shot through here
and then i'm going to move on to a
different method
you can see it's not quite ready to kick
skype out there's a little bit
of a hurdle still to get these going
sometimes
house
should we hold the audience for another
phone to try
anybody have a verizon phone maybe
horizon
yeah you want to try and share your
internet
i'll keep talking for a minute while uh
see if she reconnects in here
oh thank you oh okay gotcha um
okay so
ryan if you join in say hello
okay let me keep talking and i'm going
to come back to that
so there's uh a number of different
applications that uh this this can work
in here
and other different uh scenarios excuse
me
you're starting to see companies use
this for uh
contacting them online directly through
the site for customer support
okay this is uh a tool called a
commercial offering called kite that
does uh that does that already
and so the the advantage of of doing
support like this the
the scenario that i imagine at least is
when i'm
having trouble with my business banking
site as as i sometimes do
and i have to call into their customer
support and get elevated to the right
type of rep to deal with
the right part of the website that i'm
working on
for business wire transfers is a pain
pain point for me because we're an
international business
and i have to explain to them my account
number what i'm doing all these things
like several different times as you go
through the chain right of calling them
on the phone
but if you can contact customer support
directly where you
are in the application and it's built
into the app so they know
everything about you already they
already know that you're logged in
they already know what you're doing on
the site they may already know what
error you just triggered
all of that can be sent to the customer
rep right away
right so that that concept is um i think
a powerful one for uh doing customer
service that you can have a lot more
yes that's it almost
and this is the other fun part of webrtc
is
echoing all right i muted my microphone
phone
here because i'm also streaming my audio
to mariana through this
so uh mariana can we can we hear you
you can't hear me
no i think you're muted okay
well let's try
this okay
now can you hear me yes i can yes
all right how was that for a smooth
amazing right amazing we only had to try
several tools couple wifi's
uh i i was i was you know rubbing some
sticks together back here
quite amazing right so this is super
smooth but but still
you know we're on the bleeding edge here
so bear with us this is this is a tool
called the pure dot in
which is one of the companies that is
building
simple video conference solutions using
webrtc
the nice thing about this uh this tool
and others like it like v-line and
there's another company
called speak that's combining webrtc
with traditional telephony
solutions is that you
they they say these things will
basically replace your phone number
right so i'm
you know i will be at aaron's son
and that's the way you contact me and it
goes to my phone it goes anywhere right
kind of like google voice did
so there's some pretty cool uh
applications of this i want to
uh give mariana a quick chance to
talk about some of the problems or
interesting challenges just trying to
turn it so you can see everybody here
part of everybody with the design
aspects mariana
is at the beach right now in costa rica
um literally uh and uh she's our lead
designer at agility so brianna just like
you know a minute what's uh what's
painful and fun about this
um so so there's so much possibilities
with real time
and how you can now connect people over
browsers
uh some of the difficulties of building
the ux
for this is definitely graceful
degradation
what happens when the connection is not
strong enough
or when you don't know if the other
person is connected or can receive your
calls
another thing that is very important is
making sure that the technology enhances
the experience
and not that the experience is
working around what technology you can
bring into
so so here it's very important to
remember that
although this is very new and
challenging and interesting
we should always care about how the
experience for the user is going to be
and where it's great to bring it in
and then finally feedback
is very important so it's very important
to know
when you are sharing your camera or your
audio
when you're using it there's
privacy concerns and there's also things
like what
what is happening in the environment
around
others what's also happening in the
system
so feedback is not only about a user's
actions anymore
it's also about other people that are
trying to interact with you
and other systems that that could also
possibly interact
that's a one minute ux
thanks marianna uh so there's a couple
privacy things built into webrtc
when when you go into one a site using
it for the first time
and say i want to have that video chat
with you it's going to
ask you to allow or deny my access to
your camera
to your video and your microphone so
that can't be done without your
permission
and i don't know if you can see on the
screen there's uh
you know a red circle on the browser
that is controlling browser tab that is
controlling the camera right now
so that if i leave this tab and i go do
other stuff it helps me to remember in
addition to my little green light
that mariana can still see what we're
doing here
too right so you've got some things
built into webrtc like that but you need
to build it in
uh as as well to the design itself
any any questions for her before i move
on
yeah talk about ux ui is there a
possibility
to blur or get a sort of blurring
without putting it using
the camera yes definitely so one of the
cool things about this is once you have
the video screen you can manipulate it
that's not built into webrtc so to speak
but you can write other code around the
video streams and manipulate it as you
like before you present it to the user
so there's a
there's a demo um online for
um converting your video
feed into ascii characters and it's
actually pretty darn responsive you know
so you bring up the page and you
and you see you there but it's converted
all into ascii characters on a white
background and if you move your hands
around
it it keeps up with you pretty well so
the matrix basically
sorry the matrix basically it is the
matrix that's right
is it possible since you you said that
it's using uh some
html5 tag to show it is it possible to
do any
type of transforms via css
yeah is it possible to do any css
transforms
around yeah like do a blur or something
like that
yeah it should be okay yeah it should be
that it's
once once it's out there it's yeah it is
just like any other video element would
be in html5 and
and you can certainly apply overlays to
it with css or whatever you want
to do a mask of some kind absolutely
yeah you do whatever you want with it at
that point
cool all right somebody else is joining
excellent
i know who that is
somebody in this room because there's an
echo i know that much
cool so um
so how is that getting another string
from another player
if it's peer-to-peer
the servers mixing them together
yes exactly so webrtc is peer-to-peer
so there's two ways that you can do it
um if if you're going to limit the
number of people
in the conversation then you just have a
star pattern where
if there's three of us in the call then
i have to have two peer-to-peer
connections one to each individual
person and
everyone else does too obviously that
doesn't scale very well
so there are commercial providers that
will basically mix the streams together
and so you just have one peer-to-peer
connection to that server
obviously if you go that route if you
know for some reason the
the peer-to-peer or the privacy nature
of it is important to you you're losing
that
if you go to multi-party conferencing
solutions
but companies are coming out with that
for sure
okay all right
so i call this manual handshaking by the
way skype
because i still have to let people know
hey i'm going to call you and stuff so
this is all part of the
evolving standard hey there's allen
actually good uh
alan uh just saying hello this is alan
naranjo
he did most of the pretty much all of
the
development on this so
all right so let me go back to the
slides now
okay so we were around here
okay so we talked about inline support
as being an option
here whoever's joined in the room you
might want to go unmute for me
so obviously video conferencing
solutions but to be honest
if you're thinking this is awesome i
should build a skype color you're
already a little late that's a little
bit of a lame
solution at this point because there's a
lot of companies like appear in and
v-line doing a good job of that already
i mentioned healthcare though so let's
talk about this one for a second
a telemedicine app okay this is this
screenshot is from a real telemedicine
app but
so far as i know it's not using webrtc
but there are companies who are saying
they're working on it using webrtc
and the um the advantage of webrtc in
those situations is that it's
peer-to-peer
encrypted which means that you are more
likely to be able to get hipaa
compliance
for remote telemedicine offerings
because webrtc's got
those key architectural components built
into it already
that are going to help with that sort of
oversight
so whether it's a regulation oversight
or whether it's just sort of a corporate
thing that hey we want to be
really careful about corporate espionage
and stuff and keep our
internal communications with remote
workers secure
webrtc is is worth considering for that
uh insurance claims so imagine so right
now this is not
widely supported yet in mobile but
especially once apple gets on board and
they've joined the
standards committee now so i think they
will get on board with it
uh so once this is available on ios and
even better
if they make it like native to ios not
necessarily through the browser
imagine you know you get in a car
accident and the
insurance company you call them up to
report it
and they immediately file the claim with
you remotely through your phone
saying you know can can will you allow
me to turn on your video camera on your
phone i want you to walk me around
the car show me the damage show me you
know
where the accident happened and claims
adjusters no longer need to come out
and see your car right so there are
things like that where this sort of
technology making that easier to build
directly into applications could be
extremely disruptive to
the whole industry
i think one of the cool things about
this is just
in context communications in general so
a simple example of that
you've got your real-time data dashboard
your corporate data dashboard and you
can do
conferencing around that data
directly in the app no need to have a
separate go-to meeting or something like
that manipulate the data together that
sort of thing get a question
yes
are you able to report
you can there's nothing built into
webrtc about recording but you can take
that stream and feed it to something to
record
so yeah absolutely
one of the things people talk about a
lot is building this into gaming so a
simple example is just building video
chat into gaming this is a demo game for
google called cubeslam
where you're playing silly games but
you're at least seeing the person you're
playing against so that makes it a
little bit more interesting
but beyond that there's also come back
to that one in a moment
other applications like this this one
called banana bread
which is a first person shooter game
that's using the data channel webrtc
for the data communications between
users so it has nothing to do with video
chat or audio
it's just sending the coordinates of
where your player
player is in the game that sort of thing
and
one other example of the data data
channel that's really cool to consider
is pure cdn which uh i believe is the
first company
acquired that is based on webrtc
technology
yahoo just bought them a few months ago
and what pure cdn does it's really cool
is is basically they
serve the images on your website to
other people from uh and so
let's try it again two people are
visiting your website they're both in
webrtc enabled browsers
i was there first so when you go after
me you're going to get the images and
assets from my computer
so instead of paying akamai
right for hosting your images because
you don't want to
post them on your own servers you're
actually not paying
anyone because webrtc is pulling it from
other people who are
on the site right now it may be closer
to you geo location lines
maybe closer to you um they obviously
have to be in the right web rtc browsers
but still
for a company the size of yahoo right if
you can just shave a couple percent
of people from you know serving the
images from a cdn somewhere else
that probably adds up to big bucks right
so it this is an example where
even without widespread adoption you can
build some pretty powerful
cool stuff so that's
that's right yeah exactly well it
i mean if you're a media
content company and you currently have
customers where you're shipping
the data to them encrypted
you said this is encrypted so is there
something built in that's going to
prevent
one of your video
clients that are that's sharing the cdn
you know like you just explained from
grabbing it and sending it off to 10
other people that
are not now if you're
the my peer in the connection
then once you get the data you know you
have it right
in clear text or you know in its native
form and you can do whatever you want
with it
the only thing the encryption is buying
us is a
man-in-the-middle attacks someone can
snoop the traffic between us and get
anything valuable
out of it just like an ssl connection
typically you're not doing private
assets on the subsidiary
yeah yeah this is yeah pure cdn that's
not that
in that use case it's not going to
matter
yes so regarding your cdn
and you know there well there's perhaps
a potential for something like a replay
attack
or you know ejecting religious code or
something
i think that sounds intriguing
to be honest i don't i mean i'm not a
security expert so i'm not i can't speak
up on top of my head whether or not
that's
possible in this or whether the
sandboxing around
the data channels would i guess
whatever you know small package of data
you're sending along with it
you know like this company here sydney
probably has some way to mitigate that
right like uh
uh
so he's actually uh what they do like
they they have a hashtag check
first in the fashion matches and it
doesn't match uh they
they throw it out and that happens too
often from the same period
they've on it i kill them
uh i don't know how we're doing on time
here but there's awesome questions and
stuff so i'm you know i don't leave
until one o'clock tomorrow
so i'm good but um but i don't want to
keep others
maybe what i can do is mention two
things real quick and then
i have code and some other tabs that i
can show
and i'm happy to take more questions but
i also don't want to
try to respect people's time um so we're
working on
uh a book in our company um
that is about uh using these
technologies uh i brought a
it's a i brought a few copies that i
would be happy to give away
uh actually our book is not done yet so
i'm being a very creative guy i put a
sheet of paper
over a real book that i will give to you
so it's actually like a bonus because
what you get
is a it's a real book not about node.js
but one i happen to really like that we
bought a bunch of copies of the lean
entrepreneurs
startup kind of but the fancy sheet of
paper that i've
put with it does have a promo code for a
free copy of our book
the beta release and it should be in
about two weeks so that's
one quick plug the other second quick
plug is if you're into this stuff
uh anything i mentioned we have a free
one of the weeklies with a free weekly
newsletter called realtimeweekly.com
that
i encourage you to check out so that's
that's it for my plugs um i'm going to
take more questions or
show you a couple code snippets
yes um
can you put this on the phone or is that
just
marketing uh on the talkbox website
you're saying they
they have like a picture of their app
mommy on phone
yeah so web um
yes and no right so we did have at least
one person here who was probably on an
android device and a chrome browser that
was able
am i right that that was getting the
the video stream from me that's still
through the browser
google does plan on putting uh is my
understanding
webrtc native into the android operating
system so that you can use it in native
apps as well
hopefully ios will in the future but
the other thing that companies like
talkbox are doing is
they're basically as i understand it
re-implementing webrtc themselves
in objective-c or wherever they need it
so that they can include it in the apps
or they're using a gateway to
then be able to connect webrtc with say
a flash
application together
not that flash would work on ios either
but
theoretically theoretically
okay so uh
alan i think he's new
i think you're probably muted or you're
smiling quietly
um
that's how you roll uh emily you want to
say anything about the the coding on
this i have a couple of the
snippets up here that i can show if you
want to
talk about anything
well um what we're doing is
uh
using uh pop-up for a real-time
casino so
we use two ways of connecting
people first is with the channel
so that's uh i don't know what you're
showing
the messages or comments that people
send
a little bit i'm showing the uh the
publish and subscribe methods from
pubnub right now
yeah that's that's what this application
is doing uh
at least the one that you're using for
showing the slides
so um what we do
is uh we subscribe everyone in
this application to the same channel and
uh we send different
here we have the
web part cc percent which is
sending a string to
public and that's what we use
when somebody calls like if you
uh sort of call me through the
presentation
what we do is we have a peer-to-peer
connection
and then you notified me
that you're uh you want to stream your
video and audio to me and then i'll do
the same thing
to you and that's how we make uh
a call possible so
i don't know if you could hear that okay
in the back so of super quick recap
what what you're doing in the
handshaking is you're
basically exchanging identifiers and the
networking information between the two
clients
and then that unique identifier for the
client through
we're using the pubnub api here i can
publish my stream
and my unique identifier in order
for people to communicate with me and
then i can
subscribe to another there's a couple
ways i can
complete the answer from them but
one is is to use the subscribe method
based on their unique
identifier and then pubmup handles
the fact that we've now said okay these
are our two streams and we can
talk to each other and it's establishing
underneath its api the actual webrtc
connection
and in my case when i'm subscribed to
alan
and i've gotten his stream back here i'm
just you know passing that in to the
source of a video attack
so it is nine o'clock i think i should
stop myself there but again i'm happy to
talk to anybody else who wants to come